Cody was just saying how much he hates
seeing stinky regular people at the
airport he was just going you know what
I hate I hate when I walk into the
airport I see someone who
smells like Irish Spring you know that
[__] poor regular soap you know that
stench it has on your skin that's what
he was saying that's actually the soap I
use right
now that's how you try to stay in touch
with the people yeah what soap do you
use uh I don't use any what's the bougie
soap you don't use soap no no that's why
I wear these pants man after I after I
get Buck Fever yeah you after I [__]
shoot I'm
like wait what's Buck Fever it's after
you uh kill an animal and you it's like
the fever you get from like taking from
the land wait what yeah like in a good
way or a bad way it's like it's like is
it a fever like I just can't stop yeah
you can't stop killing them yeah yeah
yeah you shoot the dad and then you move
on to the kids I must kill again yeah no
it's I think it's a it's a it's a
feeling people get it's a really sacred
feeling it's supposed to be bad no no
it's a it's like a weird acknowledgement
of what you've just done gotcha so you
you take from the land oh I see and your
body goes through a trauma response
basically gotcha you know it's the Big O
for um for hunters for hunters yeah any
any hunter is just they're thinking
about coming to this spaceship and
shooting us with their rifle as we
desecrate this sacred moment the
ultimate Buck Fever yeah
yeah killing a human The Forbidden Fever
The Forbidden Fever The Forbidden
fever he's not a bad guy he just went
for the Forbidden fever anyways yeah why
why do we get into Buck Fever I because
your pants I guess yeah yeah something
before that you were talking about soap
yeah after I had the Buck Fever yeah
yeah and I'm
like then I reach into about the I'm
about the B then I reach into the buck
and I just get that lining of fat from
the bottom of its stomach and I
just oh that's what you wash with oh
Jesus
Christ that's graphic as
hell e dude I know I had you there
visually I just had to take you
there I can honestly say I was not
expecting
that jerking off with deer fat ladies
and gentlem man what's his name who
showed his [__] on YouTube uh oh
[__] Kevin yeah Kevin yeah yeah Kevin
like leave it up to Kevin to do that
yeah he would definitely do that jerking
it with deer
fat this is what it sounds
like yeah man how's your run tired what
you tired I am tired yeah I'm yeah I'm
pretty [__] up from that honestly just
just the worst interview question yeah
yeah was was it
long yeah I don't get why people do that
stuff not for
me um how many miles was it 26 oh kind
of stupid yeah yeah I prefer to run to
the
fridge there's so many [__] signs out
there from people that said like I'd eat
26.2 pizzas instead I prefer that it's
like how is this helping me that's so
man that's great I know spite sign yeah
I know just waking up
just yeah all these are running today
and I'm going to try to make their lives
awful I don't know why there's just a
random redneck in the middle of New York
yeah exactly City redneck no people
people came out for it dude showed out
oh my God like I couldn't believe like
there was never a section where there
wasn't like thousands of people standing
on the street for 26 miles you should
have just parked it and did a
set like a like a standup set any kind
of set any set comedians find out about
did a running set yeah yeah yeah
26 that's kind of dumb though you should
ate 26 pizzas
instead there was some good signs out
there my favorite one I saw near the
beginning and it was a little it had a
little alien on it and it said take me
to your Finish Line I don't know why I
giggled so hard at that I was like that
is so [__] dumb that's the dumbest
cutest sign ever yeah and it made me
smile for like another two miles after
that and then you remember your Finish
Line I that what you said to yourself
yeah I like literally I will you know
I'm heading there right now take me to
your
finish nice [__] good dude yeah that
shit's [__] funny yeah I'm
laughing it's it's funny it's just
stupid and dumb I'm creasing mate what
I'm creasing mate what is that like you
know English person I'm creasing mate
I'm creasing mate that's how hard I'm
laughing yeah no no no I'm laughing hard
as hell at that
[Laughter]
one some other ones some
good oh I saw one other one that was one
guy listening right now what are your
feet looking like
bro uh the same the same yeah no I'm
sore as [__] though it was a hard hard
course
yeah a lot of snuck up on you what you
say you didn't get the time you wanted
yeah cuz I was like I just I went out
way too hard you know like I talked to
my coach beforehand he's like we set up
this plan I talked to him for like 30
minutes like first seven miles you're
going to do 845 Pace second 7 miles you
know you're going to do 8:30 and then
and then comes like the Brooklyn Bridge
or whatever you know you're going to
expect that Hill everything we talked
for 30 minutes I had this detail plan
and the race gun went off and I just
forgot everything and just ran like so
hard for no reason damn so that kind of
[__] me and I felt so good until mile
20 and then it just like everything just
came crumbling Ling down shut down and I
started just like hobbling I was like
run walking which was embarrassing cuz
there was a lot of people there like a
lot of fans there cuz you know I made it
very known that I was doing this race a
lot of people on the sidelines with like
yes like I couldn't believe how many
people actually and they a lot of them
near the end saw me just suffering
they're just crumpling their
signs yeah
exactly go Cody oh
were you just cheering for that guy no
were you just cheering for that guy
walking no I wasn't
no
yeah they're they're
crying you used to inspire me man you're
so full of [__] dude what happened to
you bro delete that [__]
Channel
[__] damn no but it was still a great
day like yeah that that race is [__]
just hobbling in hell yeah literally
that's the weirdest meet and greet ever
yeah
[Laughter]
literally like like almost almost
throwing up well since you ain't running
bro can we get a picture I'm running I'm
good yeah no can we get a picture real
quick since you ain't running or
anything some dude actually did that
another Runner came up to me as I was in
like the pain cave like literally just
like one foot after the other one foot
after the other and he came up he was
like bro can I get a selfie and he's
just like he's like that [__] guy at
the ultra marathon you know like 23 just
has felt pain yet in his life you know
running like at a like six minute pace
he's like oh [__] yo can I get a
picture I'm like slap you on the back as
you're trying to throw
up oh [__] my bad bro throw up blood oh
dude my bad and then you see his
Instagram later and it's like just
dusted Cody Co LOL dude looked bad L
next slide just finished yeah yeah St
Cody Co I used to watch watch the guy's
videos all the time he's [__] slow
man yeah yeah safe to say I will not be
watching him anymore after this is not a
good honestly pathetic like can't think
of a better word than that this guy's a
whole YouTube channel but he runs
[Laughter]
bad I don't know as bad it's possibly be
a bad Runner but he's like a bad
Runner so he's bad at this it's
[Laughter]
sad